jahrelang haben angelika b und wilfried
w frauen in ihrem haus eingesperrt
bestialisch gequält und gefoltert
der fall höchster ist das böseste
verbrechen und das grausamste verbrechen
über das sich jemand berichtete
[Musik]
mein name ist markus brekenkamp ich bin
seit 34 jahren bild reporter mit
schwerpunkt verbrechen
gerichtsberichterstattung ich habe über
tausende verbrechen berichtet aber der
fall höchster der lässt mich einfach
nicht los
[Musik]
während wilfried w in der
untersuchungshaft zu den vorwürfen
schwieg hat angelika b ausgesagt und die
schuld auf ihren ex mann geschoben jetzt
steht das hopper von höchster vor
gericht wilfried w ist das wirklich der
richtige kann das wirklich die person
sein gegen die diese schwerwiegende
vorwürfe erhoben werden es ist angelika
die die idee hatte wir müssen die frauen
an kennen wilfried wird das immer wieder
tun ich würde diesen menschen als
gefährlich bezeichnet
wird kontaktanzeigen abgegeben wir haben
ungefähr 1500 frauen ermitteln können
die sich auf diese kontaktanzeige
gemeldet haben wir haben insgesamt um
die 1100
beweismittel gesichert es gab zahlreiche
videofilme die täter haben ihre taten
teilweise gefilmt
[Musik]
wir haben natürlich als boulevardzeitung
und reißerische überschriften
wie gewalt die dort passiert ist ist so
einzigartig so unfassbar dass ich glaube
dass die begriffe folter bestie und hexe
von höchster genau die richtigen sind
[Musik]
d
heinlein
wie entscheiden
flash
nein
ende
die 10
leben
maxi kuchar
[Musik]